bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
parlement hebdo sommes ensemble pour 45
minutes d'actualité politique et
parlementaire avec perrine bonsoir
bonjour et semaine sous tension les
bonnets rouges ne décolère pas à vent
debout contre l'écotaxe et les plans
sociaux qui touchent la bretagne
le gouvernement reste ferme et condamne
les dégradations contre les biens
publics bataille politique aussi autour
du contrat et comme au front plus pour
récolter la taxe gauche et droite se
renvoient la responsabilité du dossier
on parlera aussi des nouveaux mariés du
centre udi modem après onze ans de
séparation jean louis borloo et françois
bayrou ont scellé leurs retrouvailles
autour de l'alternative c'est le nom de
cette nouvelle alliance au centre
et puis le plus de l'hebdo vous emmène
au quai d'orsay dans les pas de
dominique de villepin incarné par
thierry lhermitte le film inspiré de la
bd éponyme est sorti cette semaine entre
comédie et politique les coulisses de la
diplomatie française on en parle tout à
l'heure et avec nous cette semaine sur
le plateau pour commenter cette
actualité politique et parlementaire
hebdomadaire chantal jouanno bonjour ma
jolie d'être avec nous sénatrice groupe
u10 bientôt une des modems alternative
des modems réussi eu des us et donc vous
changez pas les gens les deux ça
rassemble et déjà les deux tombent
d'accord
eh bien écoutez on va commencer la
semaine car avec une semaine qui
commence par le deuil et l'hommage aux
deux journalistes exécutés de rfi au
mali
ghislaine dupont claude verlon morts en
service pour l'information les deux
journalistes ont été enlevés puis
exécutées à la sortie d'une interview
d'un chef touareg c'était le samedi de
novembre à kidal dans le grand nord du
mali
hommage unanime en france cette semaine
au parlement
sénateurs et députés ont observé une
minute de silence à la mémoire des deux
reporters de rfi l'acte a depuis été
revendiqué par aqmi al qaïda au maghreb
islamique
accéder à la propriété n'est pas si
simple
en france c'est ce que révèle une étude
réalisée par le courtier en ligne
empruntis plus d'un français sur deux
possède son propre bien mais dans ce
domaine la france est en avant dernière
à l'échelle européenne
julien chollet l'accès à la propriété
reste aujourd'hui hors de portée du plus
grand nombre
c'est le constat que dresse le parisien
aujourd'hui en france d'abord le prix
d'achat moyen serait temps aussi
l'atteindre et cette année 220 milles
387 euros soit dix mille euros de plus
en un an
le journal tire également la sonnette d
alarme quant aux disparités
territoriales 220000 euros permettra
l'achat de 84 mètres carrés à marseille
68 à lyon et seulement 26 m² à paris des
moyennes qui se base sur les achats
réalisés car en réalité le prix du mètre
carré disponible serait plutôt à la
baisse depuis quatre ans les classes
moyennes en revanche se ferait plutôt
rare parmi les acheteurs
en clair seuls les ménages aisés
continuerait d'acheter une réalité bien
loin de la france de propriétaires à
laquelle aspire et nicolas sarkozy
autre problème les avantages fiscaux à
destination des acquéreurs mise en place
sous son quinquennat n'aurait pas eu
l'effet escompté
si vous devenez un avantage fiscal
s'ancrer d'appartements supplémentaires
vous allez juste surenchère et le pré
d'hébergement existants selon lui le
marché immobilier aurait surtout besoin
de nouveaux logements
là où la demande est la plus forte créer
sa maison achetée son appartement
investir sur sur les quinze ou vingt ans
ou 25 ans qui viennent sont des actes
forts zone de confiance fort et
aujourd'hui le climat plus anxiogène
reste donc à redonner confiance aux
investisseurs et aux ménages
alors on va passer maintenant au mardi
avec ce rejet unanime et inédit au sénat
d'un projet de loi écoutez donc mardi au
sénat les sénateurs ont tous rejeté le
projet de loi sur les retraites
socialistes compris
il faut dire que le texte avait été
totalement détricoté par les sénateurs
et donc ne satisfaisait plus aucun des
groupes politiques
écoutez la ministre marisol touraine à
sa sortie de l'hémicycle mardi quelque
peu désabusé ni financement ni pilotage
ni mesure de justice puisque le comte
pénibilité a été supprimé puisque le
comité de suivi a été supprimé puisque
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
et de financement de nos régimes de
retraite ont été supprimés c'est un
texte qui ne ressemblait plus à rien et
qu'ils ne pouvaient donc pas être adopté
par les socialistes et donc je me
réjouis de cette situation qui est un
peu absurde et que je regrette pour ma
part car j'aurais souhaité des débats
sans doute plus constructif mais de ce
point de vue là le travail va se
poursuivre avec l'assemblée nationale
chantal jouanno 346 voix contre zéro
c'est quand même une situation très
inédites voire presque absurde comme le
dit marisol touraine à quoi a servi le
passage au sénat
je pense que le gouvernement devra avoir
la modestie de reconnaître que son texte
était mal ficelé et s'interroger sur lui
même le vrai débat aujourd'hui c'est que
cette réforme rejetée à l'unanimité
fallu dire c'est le seul recours que le
gouvernement détient et on a un
gouvernement qui nous dit-on pia le
sénat sont des incompétents
donc on va aller discuter avec
l'assemblée nationale et sénat ne sert à
rien donc le vrai débat aujourd'hui
c'est un débat démocratique
il faut que le il faut que le
gouvernement assume ses responsabilités
et nous disent est ce que le sénat ne
sert à rien on rejette le plf
on rejette le plfss et ça n'a aucune
conséquence démocratique
c'est un véritable déni de démocratie
mais le sénat est très affaibli du fait
de sa majorité instable et à seulement
six voisins laurence pernoud la gauche
c'est le gouvernement qui est très
affaiblie c'est pas le sénat ça c'est
une réalité démocratique le scénar
reflète une réalité démocratique
le gouvernement n'en tient pas compte la
ministre sort et tu dis ça n'a aucun
intérêt de toute façon on ira discuté à
l'assemblée nationale ces extraits live
devenir finalement c'est l'assemblée
nationale c'est très exactement ce
qu'elle vient nous dire donc aujourd'hui
on a un choix démocratique à faire si
l'on considère que le sénat ne sert à
rien ce qu'elle vient de vous dire dans
ce cas là faut le supprimer ou voulez
vous le dire vous vous mettez en cause
la méthode de marisol touraine
on va très clairement quand on en arrive
là mais ça un grand compte mais en ayant
plus moi ce que je trouve ça j'ai été
ministre
on se pose même pas la question on dit
même pas bombe a coûté c'est tellement
grave et le sujet tellement important
pour notre pays qui peut pas être aussi
clivant qu'il faudrait que justement ma
on reprend le travail
on se remet autour de la table alors
parler d'un sujet qui vous concerne
puisque mardi c'était jour de mariage
17h judée de jean louis borloo et le
modem de françois bayrou annonce l'union
de leur parti retrouvailles des
centristes dispersés au fil des
élections et des scissions le mariage a
été célébré à la mutualité
sous la pluie les mariés de novembre
c'est un sujet de rabbi cas ils sont
arrivés ensemble conférence de presse
commune pour jean louis borloo et
françois bayrou qui scelle leur
retrouvailles après onze ans de
séparation
nous avons décidé de nous rassembler de
rassembler toutes nos forces
face à la situation de désarroi et de
désespérance de notre pays et nous nous
avons choisi au contraire
faire une oeuvre de construction et qui
débute évidemment par une oeuvre de
conciliation ou même de réconciliation
voici donc l'alternative alternative au
ps à l'ump mais surtout au front
national
les deux têtes d'affiché ont présenté la
charte sur laquelle il travaille depuis
des mois
objectif commun les municipales les
européennes mais aussi la présidentielle
pour les municipales certaines alliances
locales avec le ps risque de raviver les
tensions entre les deux camps grand
absent du jour françois sauvadet et jean
christophe fromantin qui critiquent ce
manque de clarté du modem à l'échelle
locale
les autres ténors salue la nouvelle
alliance
c'est le premier jour aujourd'hui c'est
une démarche de rassemblement qu'il voit
la bonne foi des uns et des autres il
voit que partout il y à des divisions ou
des mises en question ou des dissensions
idéologiques bas au fond il ya un
endroit de la vie politique française
c'est le centre où on est en capacité de
se rassembler même si nous sommes si
nous avons eu des différences deux
hommes politiques soient rassemble deux
mouvements se rassemblent au centre de
la vie politique française je crois que
c'est une preuve de bonne foi mais c'est
le début de l'histoire pour va écrire
les deux hommes assurent qu'ils iront
ensemble jusqu'à l'élection
présidentielle les une inconnue lequel
des deux sera candidat dans quatre ans
chantal jouanno vous ne craignez pas un
hold up de françois bayrou sur
l'alternative qui va chercher finalement
à se refaire une santé politique alors
que le modem était vraiment en perte de
vitesse
le premier point qui est quand même
formidable dans le contexte politique
c'est que alors que tout le monde se
divise on se rassemble ça change très
honnêtement ça change surtout après le
précédent ce sujet dans sa sphère oui
enfin
très honnêtement aujourd'hui dans le
contexte politique où on est je pense
qu'on a fait même pas le droit de pas
essayez donc je vais pas vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est garanti ça va
fonctionner ça va marcher
j'ai jamais été dans la langue de bois
je vais pas l'être aujourd'hui mais on
n'a pas le droit de pas essayer on n'a
pas le droit de ne pas expérimenter
cette nouvelle voie et puis ne pas poser
sur la table des nouvelles idées
personne ne pose sur la table de
nouvelles idées même si l'identité
politique de l'alternative reste un
petit peu floue centre droit sans trop
dominante ce qui est politique elle est
très claire juillard
un élément qui nous rassemble et qui ne
ressemble à personne c'est l'europe donc
débat déjà avant de parler des élections
présidentielles on va parler d'europe
ce qui est quand même la grande élection
de l'année dont personne ne parle parce
qu'elle est municipal m'enfin
aujourd'hui l'essentiel des
responsabilités sont en europe et ça on
a un discours très clair on a toujours
les mêmes discours sur le plan
économique on a toujours eu les mêmes
discours sur le plan écologique et ça
c'est marrant parce qu'en général on
parle d'or rarement des idées sur le
plan d'identité quand même vous dites la
vigne est très clair que françois bayrou
ne veut pas dire le mot que
l'alternative c'est bien jamais bord
lemire être droit jean louis borloo
n'aurait jamais signé et c'était une
condition très clair pour lui si
l'alliance naturelle de ce rassemblement
l'alternative n'était pas la drogue
replica vient clairement c'est très
clair c'est écrit noir sur blanc
c'est dans la charte et l'alliance
fonctionnera donc d'abord aussi sur le
terrain des municipales ça veut dire que
là aussi c'est là que la dance
fonctionne sur le terrain des
municipales voilà à paris il y à un
conseiller modem qui a rejoint le parti
socialiste il a toujours voté avec le
parti socialiste
c'est un gars le passé bah non c'est par
un cap il est parti avec les prix de
lancement les modems sortant dans
certaines municipalités qui avait fait
alliance avec le parti socialiste pour
reconduire cette alliance pour les
prochaines municipales
ça dépend beaucoup du contexte locaux
très honnêtement non ça dépend beaucoup
des contextes locaux mais on aura
toujours des à lyon serait très clair ça
dépend des histoires ça dépend de
reconduction mais la très honnêtement
par exemple à paris on avait un modem
qui était modem et qui maintenant par
avec le parti socialiste
il fait plus partie de l'alternative mai
à dijon par exemple avec françois
rebsamen est ce que les modems sortant
pourraient reconduire leur alliance avec
françois rebsamen pour les municipales
de mars prochain
a priori c'est un gros point de débat
qui explique la position de sauvages
alors écoutez je vous rose de voir
comment la nouvelle alliance est
accueilli à l'ump dans les rangs du
parti socialiste réactions recueillies
par l amont d'un gaza est radical je
peux pas faire d'ingérence dans un
couple qui vient de se former
donc
ils sont les avancées j'ai un peu de mal
à voir quelle est la ligne politique
mais voilà c'est leur problème c'est pas
nous si ça donne un peu plus de tonus à
l'opposition si ça nous donne d'autres
idées sur les capable de construire
ensemble quelque chose l'ump a été
constituée pour unir la droite et le
centre
il ya quelques mois déjà qu'on a compris
que la droite était pas unique et
maintenant voilà le centre qui s'en va
la vie du centre
voilà bon bah c'est un segment de droite
qui se recompose après c'est leur
affaire qui vivent leur vie
françois bayrou a annoncé cette semaine
qu'il allait être candidat aux
municipales à pour en mars prochain
l'ump va sans doute lui mettre un
candidat en face à l'as que c'est déjà
la guerre entre l'alternative et l'ump
qui est quand même le principal parti
d'opposition il faut voir qui est le
mieux placé a priori c'est françois
bayrou qui est le mieux placé pour
justement tenir et porté porté
l'opposition dans ses commentaires
oui dans ses commentaires y en a qui
voient clair c'est eric woerth
voilà très clairement enfin franchement
ces petites guéguerres d'hommes enfin
nous on arrive à marier les autres comme
quelque chose que on a été les premiers
à marier des hommes quelque chose dont
nous mêmes plus pourrait s'inspirer mai
mais très honnêtement le vrai débat
aujourd'hui c'est comment on apporte des
idées nouvelles sur la table comment on
conduit l'opposition comment on arrête
enfin le vrai débat aujourd'hui c'est
que les personnes arrêtent d'être
convaincu par des populistes quoi c'est
ça le vrai débat vous poser comme une
alternative est ce que c'est aussi une
alternative à l'ump quel est votre
positionnement par rapport à l'ump a été
notre allié naturel dès lors que elle
est républicaine
par contre l'ump localement qui ferait
des alliances ou qui suppose qu'ils
seraient d'accord pour des alliances
avec le front national n'est pas notre
allié nature est trop à droite
vaki qui prendrait clairement position
pour le front national ou qui ouvrirait
sa porte ou qui laisserait sa porte
ouverte comme on a pu l'entendre
récemment est ce qui nous a amené à dire
que le centre n'avait plus adroits sa
place de toute façon il une manif au
sein de l'ump ça ne vient pas d'alliance
possibles c'est très clair et pour 2017
est ce que les choses sont déjà définis
est ce que vous avez envisagé pour
choisir lequel des 2 portera le centre
est ce que ça est-ce que c'est précisé
dans l'achat il y aura des primaires
par exemple on fait de la politique
autrement donc on n'arbitre pas
aujourd'hui notre candidat pour 2017
selon des procédures qui seraient les
procédures obscures donc il y aura un
mode élections démocratiques
probablement des primaires probablement
parce que c'est plus démocratique
a priori la chasse est pas écrit noir
sur blanc parce que honnêtement on
n'avait pas envie que les journalistes
se focalise trop sur ce point mais bon
on sait très bien que ça vous préoccupe
c'est bon signe
on poursuit la semaine chantal jouanno
avec la polémique autour des com ouvre
la société chargée de collecter
l'écotaxe et d'installer les portails
électroniques
la gauche dénonce les clauses du contrat
signé sous la droite
le groupe socialiste du sénat demande la
création d'une commission d' enquête et
le parquet de nanterre a rouvert le
dossier
haha vick a suspendu la semaine dernière
l'écotaxe nom finit pas d'agiter
l'hémicycle c'est maintenant le contrat
déco move la société en charge de la
collecte de l'écotaxe qui remis en cause
les ministres dénonce entre autres la
part importante versée à et comme ouvre
pour collecter l'impôt
oui vous avez peu de mémoire vous qui
lorsqu'il vous étiez le gouvernement
avait fait le choix d'un partenariat
public privé signé pas madame kosciusko
morizet avec l'entreprise et comme vous
ce qui est clair c'est que ce contrat
est déséquilibrée en faveur du
partenaire privé ou en tout cas qu'il ya
là un facteur qu'il faut examiner le
contrat signé par l'ancien gouvernement
embarrasse l'ump jean françois copé
après avoir dénoncé le coût à berne
l'écotaxe accuse la gauche de faire
diversion
je ne suis pas dupe de l'écran de fumée
que même les socialistes à vouloir
mettre en avant la question de la
gestion de la collecte dont on peut
considérer qu'il est élevé je voudrais
aussi que les socialistes
se souviennent que les collectivités
territoriales ont tout voulu bénéficier
de l'éco taxe et la mettre en oeuvre le
plus rapidement possible thierry mariani
ancien ministre des transports mis en
cause pour avoir signé le décret
d'application de l'écotaxe en mai 2012
reproche aujourd'hui au gouvernement son
manque d'honnêteté
ça fait un an et demi que la gauche est
au pouvoir ça fait un an et demi qui
connaissent ce contrat par coeur
ça fait un an et demi que les
responsables des collectivités locales
de gauche attendent que de toucher
l'écotaxe pour leur collectivité
les élus socialistes viennent
d'approuver la création d'une commission
sénatoriale
elle tentera de faire toute la lumière
sur le contrat signé entre la précédente
majorité et la société comme move
chantal jouanno
chacun se renvoie la responsabilité de
ce dossier ce qui génère cacophonie et
tumulte on a du mal à comprendre
pourquoi tout le monde à l'époque était
d'accord et aujourd'hui plus personne
qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est un
concours d'hypocrite
bah écoutez vous avez raison de rappeler
qu en 2008 vote à l'unanimité ce qui on
peut aussi rappeler accessoirement en
février 2013 le débat est remis sur la
table parce qu'il y avait un problème de
système de compensation fin de paiement
forfaitaire revoter à l'unanimité alema
limité sur le grenelle mais voilà nous
essayons dans le projet de loi de
finance par exemple et sénateurs avaient
voté sur l'écotaxe il février 2013 vote
à l'unanimité sur le principe du
paiement forfaitaire
donc quand même ils ont tous la mémoire
courte le principe de l'éco taxe est un
très bon principe parce que je rappelle
quand même que les 25 % des 600 milles
poids lourds qui sont des poids lourds
en transit qui traverse notre pays
aujourd'hui ne payent rien que pour son
un tir je suis pour son maintien
le vrai débat aujourd'hui c'est que
cette affaire'' ecomouv masquer le fait
qu'on va abandonner cette écotaxe mais
qu'on veut pas le dire tout simplement
et le débat sur ecomouv mais c'est
grotesque quand même les radars
automatiques comment on fait on recourt
à une société privée
est-ce que 25% c'est beaucoup vous
regardez les autres pays il y en a qui
fait là il y en a qui font plus y en a
pour les quêtes c'est plus ça vous
surprend qui est que l'anc est ce la
roue verte fait très bas alors puis en
plus pour le gouvernement pour ouvrir
une enquête mais très bien il faut se
faire un an et demi qu'ils auraient pu
faire donc qu'ils fassent cette enquête
mais qui nous disent comment ça se passe
dans d'autres pays qui nous dit
aussi combien ça coûterait si c'était
l'état qui prélevaient combien ça
coûterait ce serait 21% ou pas après
tout très bien qu'on fasse la clarté sur
l'ensemble des taxes mais à taxe
comparable
évidemment une taxe qui est prélevé sur
plusieurs points dans le territoire mais
alors mais franchement c'est un concours
d'hypocrite
quand on dit les femmes effectivement
fallait remettre les choses sur la table
devant lui dit il faut dans le pardon il
faut apaiser les choses
il a raison mais là aujourd'hui on se
prépare juste discrètement à dire que
c'est encore une mesure écologique
combat abandonnés ce qu'on a pris 32
milliards de prélèvements obligatoires
sans que personne ne bouge
mais ça parce que c'est écologique c'est
insupportable et françois rebsamen qui
demandent une commission denquête au
sénat vous soutenez cette demande
pourrait voir un petit peu plus clair
est-ce que vous aurez envie de
participer à cette commission denquête
mais qu'ils veulent ce qu'il veut faire
la claque la clarté très bien d'ailleurs
mais je vous dis il aurait pu le faire
se fait un nom qui sont pouvoir mamie
qui sont au pouvoir ils pouvaient le
faire
voilà le dossier ouvert mais mais mais
le vrai débat c'est qu'ils veulent
simplement abandonné cette écotaxe il
faut le dire il faut le dire quand on
laisse un portique se faire démonter
c'est qu'on veut l'abandonner alors
justement on va revenir sur cet
imbroglio autour des coms pour essayer
de comprendre les dessous de ce contrat
c'est le nôtre zoom économiques de la
semaine
bonjour jean louis gombeaud
bonjour bonjour que tian bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous
alors est ce que l'état peut remettre en
cause puisque visiblement c'est le
souhait de carrasco vie si ce
partenariat conclu avec ecomouv cdu
coûtera cher d'abord c'est un premier
point donc là aussi puisqu'on parle de
coûts va falloir comparer les coûts de
la poursuite du processus et les coûts
du fait que la france retirerait sa
signature pour peut évidemment que la
commission d' enquête et le parquet
conclu au fait qu'il n'y a rien et je
pense qu'il n'y a rien donc
mais à partir de là ça sert à rien ça
sert peut-être à tranquilliser la
population qui saura à travers les
commissions que si je ne me trompe pas
qu'en fin de compte il n'y a rien bon
mais ça pose le fait qu'il n'y ait rien
s'il n'ya rien ce que ne sais pas
évidemment signé rien ça pose quand même
deux problèmes l'un qui vient d'aborder
madame jouanno sur la question des taxes
écologiques et l'autre sur le principe
même du par
de narnia public-privé partenariat
public privé qui est une innovation une
invention anglaise et qui se répand
partout notamment dans la ville de
monsieur ayrault nantes avec le fameux
aéroports contesté par les écologistes
cette fois mais je ne parlais pas de la
question écologique et la question
financière qu'est ce que c'est que le
partenariat public privé c'est un moyen
pour l'état de masquer sa crise
financière c'est à dire qu'on confie et
madame jouanno là dessus a raison et
tout le monde sera d'accord avec elle si
c'était l'état qui le faisait serez
coûter très cher ils n'auraient pas les
moyens de faire pourquoi fait-il parce
qu'en fait ils recouraient était prévu
parce qu'il n'a pas les moyens de le
faire et il transforme en réalité ce
qu'on aurait fait ce que ce serait
appelée créances s'ils s'étaient
endettés pour faire lui-même le
processus on transforme ça en loyer mais
au bout du bout ça revient exactement la
même chose donc je pense qu'il ya une
réflexion à bordes veux faire c'est si
l'état n'a pas les moyens de mettre sur
pied une taxe écologique de cette nature
faut-il de faire avant de rétablir ses
finances publiques soient avec vous a
dit que ça ne renvoyait à une époque
à l'époque des fermiers généraux de la
monarchie est ce que c'est normal pour
vous qu'une société étrangère et privés
collecte un impôt français c'est pas
choquant ça c'est choquant dans le
principe mais en fait ça existe déjà
avec la tpp voir là même la tva donc
mais là il s'agissait donc un peu plus
on franchit quand même installé à dire
qu'on confie elle s'était privé de
recouvrir le territoire de partager et
de gérer non seulement nommé de gérer le
processus
je voudrais quand même aborder un point
qu'aborder madame jouanno qui est tout à
fait pertinent et qu'on doit discuter
sur la taxe écologique est ce que la
taxe et que les taxes écologiques ont de
montrer quelque part leur efficacité
parce que ça c'est un problème
l'allemagne adopté le système pour un
prix comparable vous avez parfaitement
raison c'est vrai les suisses aussi j'ai
regardé pour ce mode les chiffres ça se
ça ne marcherait pas en fonction de
chantal jouanno ne sais pas ça c'est
pourquoi ça ne marche pas tout court pas
ça ça marche c'est arrivé quand même le
trafiquant en transit ça ne suffit pas
ça ne suffit pas mais sa passe est
important de regarder ça de près cinq
ans
six ou sept pays maintenant qu'ils ont
fait donc si l'on veut et ça fonctionne
il en rit de lui le nombre de poids
lourds transitent c'est ça le point très
important de poids lourds entre 25%
c'est énorme la france est un pays de
transit parce que justement on est l'un
des pays qui ne fait rien et qui ne taxe
pas les poids lourds qui sont en transit
mais ce que ça permet de développer
finalement des moyens de transport
alternatifs un oui parce que le
financement est il ya 700 millions merci
vous à lagence justement de financement
des infrastructures de transport dont on
a besoin
dont on a besoin si on veut faire du
transport collectif si vous regardez
l'histoire allemande
ils ont leur taxe écologique eco gouv
veille comme move il au tac et quotas
depuis dix ans le rail n'a pas progressé
le rail alors qu'ils ont le même
principe que le nôtre je veux dire la
question écologique est absolument
majeurs a choisi d'abaisser un mode
attaque parce que la croissance a baissé
on aimerait bien aussi mais le transit
montrer c'est le pas whittier par
rapport aux rhein n'a pas bougé en
allemagne vous vérifierez oui alors
l'usl est chez nous engager le débat
aujourd'hui
mais merci beaucoup jean louis gombeaud
pour pour votre et éclairage et pour
cette question effectivement importante
on y reviendra peut-être tout tout à
l'heure sur est ce que c'est la faim ou
pas de la fiscalité verte oui en deux
mots ou chantal jouanno et après on va
mais je pense que de toute façon ce
qu'on appelle la taxe carbone c'est une
taxe purement symbolique parce qu'elle
est à des années lumière de ce qu'il
faudrait de ce qu'il faudrait faire
on abandonne toutes les mesures
écologiques les unes après les autres
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya un ras-le-bol
fiscale mais qui est très légitime très
très légitime mais c'est toujours
l'écologie qui en fait les frais
toujours parce que gauche et droite
confondues n'y croit pas et les bretons
en tout cas les bonnets rouges ne crois
pas non plus je monte à cheval et
révoltant maria m roy breton donc et bon
sens était forte
en tout cas les bonnets rouges mènent la
fronde contre matignon ça s'est passé
mercredi une journée marathon à la
préfecture de bretagne préfet reçoit les
différents acteurs de la contestation
pour élaborer un plan pour l'avenir de
la bretagne autour de la table des
représentants syndicaux revendications
très différentes
le gouvernement reste toutefois très
ferme
jérémie hoffmann les acteurs bretons se
sont réunis pour tenter de mettre sur
pied un plan pour l'avenir de la région
après six heures de débats le préfet de
bretagne est sorti optimiste une des
expressions qui a été employé et qui n'a
été contesté par personne c'est non au
coup de force
les conditions sont remplies pour qu'un
dialogue et quand ensemble
collectivement on construise ce pacte
d'avenir pourtant certains syndicats se
disent déçus de cette première rencontre
force ouvrière a même claqué la porte
accompagner la détresse accompagner la
formation c'est une chose
empêcher les licenciements c'en est une
autre et c'est ça qu'on est venu
chercher pour l'instant l'a pas obtenue
au même moment à l'assemblée nationale
le premier ministre affiché sa fermeté
jean marc ayrault a rejeté l'ultimatum
des bonnets rouges et affirmé que les
auteurs de violences seront convoqués
devant la justice ils sont identifiés
quel que soit le bien public
un portique un radar que ce soit une
école un équipement sportif que ce soit
dans une région dans un département une
ville ou un quartier
ce n'est pas acceptable c'est contraire
aux lois de la république
mais le débat ne se cantonne déjà plus à
la bretagne le risque de contagion est
réel dans le lot-et-garonne bornes de
paiement écotaxe a été détruite par un
incendie volontaire
est ce que vous comprenez la colère et
les revendications des bonnets rouges
breton est aussi tout c'est tous ces
débordements et tous ces violences qui
sont commises
un peu partout je comprends cette colère
par contre les deux coups taxe mais
globalement elle n'excuse pas les
débordements parce que on est quand même
dans une république et si on commence à
excuser les débordements je pense qu'on
prend tous collectivement de gros
risques
le vrai sujet aujourd'hui c'est un moine
structurelles pour la bretagne c'est que
les 700000 ports qui sont tv en bretagne
sont ensuite transformés en allemagne
c'est ça le vrai sujet c'est le manque
d'europe c'est aussi un problème
européen c'est un problème européen on a
un problème d'harmonisation fiscale et
sociale au sein de l'union européenne
qui fait qu'au sein de l'union
européenne à pratiquer le dumping social
donc c'est nous quand on dit à lui dit
on veut plus d'europe c'est justement
pour éviter ça est-ce que c'est pas un
problème français aussi la france qui a
pas forcément bien négocier ce dossier à
bruxelles
parce que c'est pas ça aussi
certainement certainement mais pourquoi
parce qu'on n'est pas très présent à
bruxelles
normalement eux ont pu défendre à fait
raison mais nous on est mal présent on
est un problème vous renvoie s'avère
leur vers l'europe tandis que c'est de
sa faute mais faisons confiance à
l'europe aussi pour trouver des
solutions
est ce qu'un risque de contagion sociale
à d'autres régions françaises pensent
que la situation économique est
tellement dramatique et la dégradation
de la note française par sonar pour
justement confirme cette situation
dramatique et comprend pas la bonne voie
que le risque de contagion est fort mais
c'est enfin on n'a pas souhaiter c'est
que je ne souhaite pas pour le
gouvernement
on change de sujet chantal jouanno avec
cette question la france est elle
raciste le débat rebondit
dix jours après les insultes dont a été
victime christiane taubira il aura donc
fallu du tour avant que les réactions
tombent des dénonciations à tardive
selon la garde des sceaux qui regrette
l'absence d'une voix forte face à la
résurgence des propos racistes en france
regardez ce reportage de jérôme rabier
chien comparer un singe par une
candidate fn hué mais surtout accueilli
avec des bananes lors d'un déplacement à
angers
la ministre de la justice christiane
taubira subit depuis plusieurs mois des
attaques racistes
exaspérée elle a décidé de sortir du
silence lors d'une interview au journal
libération elle y dénonce une attaque au
coeur de la république rappelant que le
racisme n'est pas une opinion mais un
délit
regrettant le manque de réactions
jusqu'à présent elle a profité du
conseil des ministres pour s'inquiéter
de cette résurgence de propos racistes
dans la société
je sais que lorsque on s'autorise à
tenir de tels propos en mer danger des
millions de personnes
elle a immédiatement reçu le soutien du
président de la république du premier
ministre et de l'ensemble de ses
collègues du gouvernement
nous avons une grande histoire la prof
en partageant des valeurs et donc nous
devons tous condamner ses propos mais
c'est à l'assemblée que le soutien à la
ministre a été le plus remarqué avec une
standing-ovation que lui ont réservé les
députés de la majorité
merci à tous les députés à tous les
députés qui ont manifesté d'une façon ou
d'une autre leur réprobation de telles
pratiques de tels propos
un remerciement adressé après
l'intervention du président du groupe
ump à l'assemblée christian jacob pour
dénoncer les attaques racistes avec la
plus grande fermeté
mis à part le front national qui y
voient une manière de faire diversion
dans un moment politique difficile pour
la majorité une sorte d'union sacrée des
groupes politiques semble se dessiner
contre la multiplication des attaques
racistes dont christiane taubira fait
l'objet et qui relance la question du
racisme dans la société française et
chantal jouanno pourquoi christiane
taubira suscite finalement tant de haine
à votre avis d'abord une standing
ovation aussi des membres du groupe du
centre
je veux dire quand on a été très clair
parce que c'est la paix ne se soit pas
levé pour soutenir la garde des sceaux
ils ont eu des propos il aurait pu se
lever mais bon ils ont eu des propos des
propos très clairs parce que c'est un
manque de la république c'est un membre
du gouvernement et puis c'est du racisme
elle l'a très bien dit ça n'est pas une
opinion c'est un délit
est ce que la france est raciste la
france en ce moment est fragile et je
pense que effectivement bon j'en avais
déjà parlé 1
je pense qu'effectivement il faut être
très très clair sur le fait que la
france c'est par son métissage qu'elle a
été un très grand pays toujours vous
regardez toute l'histoire de la france
vous regardez l'époque de la renaissance
c'est justement parce qu'on a apporté
des idées neuves et du sang neuf qu'on a
été un grand pays
est ce que vous constatez vous une
montée des actes et des comportements
racistes autour de vous pas autour de
moi mais je constate quand même qu'il ya
une très très grande libération de la
parole et c'est dû à quoi
ils en sont fous ils m'ont ce qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'il exclut le pays se
droitise entre et guy mais est-ce que
les débordements des uns au taux
autorisé les débordements des autres il
ya probablement des deux mais a
contrario on a l'impression parfois
qu'il appelait la parole des politiques
se ferme par peur de faire
monter le front national sur ce genre de
sujet que les politiques seraient
prudence pour ne pas être censuré sont
rapides
je craque parfois la petite politique ne
l'emportent sur l'intérêt général alors
chantal jouanno va passer à jeudi avec
une autre question de société très
sensible la question de la prostitution
pénaliser la prostitution c'est
l'objectif d'une proposition de loi
déposée à l'assemblée nationale elle
doit être examiné fin novembre le débat
a été relancé la semaine dernière avec
la publication du manifeste des 343
contre la pénalisation des
clients de prostituées avec ce slogan
touche pas à ma puce retour sur cette
polémique avec flora sauvage touche pas
à ma pub c'est le titre du manifeste des
343 publiée dans le magazine
causeur parmi les signataires qui
défendent les clients des prostituées
il y à l'écrivain frédéric beigbeder ou
l'éditorialiste eric zemmour pour eux
chacun a le droit de vendre librement
ses charmes et même d'aimer ça on a dit
voilà vous allez vous voudrez pénaliser
les clients dont qu'on déclare nous sont
tous clients c'était ça la démarche aux
syndicats les travailleurs sexuels
le manifeste a fait un tollé je pense
que c'est mon contre-productif que c'est
des personnes qui sont enfin soit
ouvertement réactionnaire ou qui en
dessous que tout cas sont pas dans une
approche féministe ou des droits des
travailleurs du sexe ça c'est les
affiches qu'on fait point de ma vie ni
si la polémique enfle depuis plusieurs
semaines c'est qu'une proposition de loi
socialiste vise à pénaliser les clients
des prostituées
pour la ministre des droits des femmes
les personnes qui se prostituent sont
pour la plupart des victimes de réseaux
90% aujourd'hui des personnes en
situation de prostitution sont des
victimes de la traite des réseaux de
l'exploitation sexuelle est-ce qu'il
faut fermer les yeux sur cette situation
en se disant que c'est une fatalité
comme certains le disent la prostitution
serait le plus vieux métier du monde
ou est ce que au contraire le progrès
c'est pas justement de construire une
société avec un cadre dans laquelle on
dit ce qui n'est pas tolérable ce qui
n'est pas admissible
la proposition de loi prévoit de
sanctionner les clients des prostituées
par une amende de 1500 euros et de
supprimer le délit de racolage public
une proposition qui va dans le bon sens
pour les associations féministes en
pénalisant le client on va en fait agir
sur la demande qui entretient l'offre
est donc en fait inverser également la
charge pénal puisque actuellement en
france depuis une loi de 2003 avec le
racolage passif ce sont des prostituées
qui sont vraiment en danger
mais pour les opposants à la
pénalisation des clients la proposition
de loi se trompe de cible en oubliant au
passage les proxénètes à votre position
chantal jouanno et éclaire sur ce sujet
vous êtes pour l'abolition de la
prostitution vous le dit dans une
tribune cosignée avec roselyne bachelot
martine billard ou encore guy geoffroy
de l'ump une tribune publiée vendredi
dans le journal le monde la prostitution
est une réalité inacceptable dans la
république
ce que dit cette tribune pour vous il
n'y a pas d'autres solutions d'autres
choix que la pénalisation la
responsabilisation du client c'est pas
la pénalisation de la prostitution c'est
la responsabilisation du client moi je
fais je vais venir j'ai fait un rapport
qu'on a rendu il ya très peu de temps
sur la situation sanitaire et sociale
des personnes prostituées à paris selon
un rapport du sénat donc indépendamment
de la question tranchée de savoir si les
clients devaient être finalisées ou pas
pénalisés c'est une situation
catastrophique et ce que s'il n'est 303
où 340 pages pourquoi je soumets
et salomé ils appartiennent juste à une
autre époque
à une époque où la prostitution était
effectivement peut être le fait de
personnes françaises plus ou moins
choisis parce que je sais pas si vous
avez des enfants mais je suis pas sûr
que ce soit l'avenir que vous souhaitiez
pour vos propres vos propres enfants
or aujourd'hui cette prostitution c'est
à 90% de prostitution de réseau d'une
violence inacceptable
et s'il ya quelques uns aux travailleurs
et quelques uns parce qu'on les connaît
tous ils sont très peu nombreux et vous
pensez bien aux travailleurs du sexe qui
viennent s'exprimer en disant mais non
mais non c'est pas comme ça mais vous
pensez bien que la très grande majorité
des victimes de réseaux ne va jamais
s'exprimer elles sont danger mort si
elle s'exprime
le vrai débat aujourd'hui c'est comme si
on ne change rien j'ai c'est comment les
protéger et comment renforcer les
réseaux si on ne change rien on fait le
jeu des réseaux et la france est une
terre d'exportation de prostitution très
clairement aujourd'hui ce qu'on a
proposé c'est d'inverser complètement
c'est de bien voir que la prostituée
d'abord une victime de s'inspirer de la
loi italienne pour se faire donc de la
protéger au sens propre et au client de
lui dire attention vous contribuez à ce
système
donc c'est pas la pénalisation parce
qu'on ne va pas les mettre en prison les
clients mais c'est au moins par une
contravention leur dire votre argent
sert au réseau mais comment faites vous
pour les dissuader alors de d'aller sur
internet ou d'aller en belgique est ce
que qadback avant clients le les
croyants se délient alors que les
clients restent clients sur internet
donc s'ils peuvent être s'ils peuvent
être victimes hugo sanctionné par une
contravention dans la rue ils sont
sanctionnés par une contravention sur
sur internet et sur internet on a le
même problème c'est que les réseaux très
très vite récupère les filles qui se
présentent sur internet
et puis deuxièmement ça va peut-être les
faire réfléchir
pardon mais quand on va voir une fille
prostituée qui a des bleus qui est qui
est obligé d'être à moitié nue dans le
bois de vincennes
ça se passe chez nous ça se passe pas
dans un pays du tiers monde ou ailleurs
ça se passe chez nous qu'on n'avait pas
nous parler de droits de l'homme à
travers le monde on laisse faire chez
nous on laisse complètement faire là en
tout cas la proposition de loi est à
l'étude à l'assemblée on va ouvrir jeudi
aux plages on ouvre une page mémoire
jeudi françois hollande qui donne le
coup d'envoi des célébrations du
centenaire de la guerre 14-18 discours à
l'elysée pour réhabiliter les quelque
650 soldats fusillés
parce qu'il avait déserté où désobéit
écouter le chef de l'état
certains furent condamnés de façon
arbitraire est passé par les armes
cent ans plus tard il nous revient
d'aborder dans un esprit de
réconciliation
cette douloureuse question des fusillés
aujourd'hui
à mon tour je souhaite au nom de la
république qu'aucun des français qui
participèrent à cette mêlée furieuse ne
soit oublié c'est pourquoi je demande au
ministre de la défense qu'une place soit
accordée à l'histoire des fusillés au
musée de l'armée aux invalides
chantal jouanno est ce que ce genre de
grands discours commémoratifs qu'il ya
important un bien sûr mais autour de
l'idée de la nation
est-ce qu'en période de crise aiguë
comme celle que traverse la france
actuellement à ce que ça peu ressoudé
justement la nation mais cc c'est plus
que jamais c'est françois hollande y
compte bien
la première guerre mondiale
ça n'empêche qu'il est vous y croyez que
ça mais ouais non mais plus que jamais
on est quand même le pays qui a fait la
terreur café l'épuration et
effectivement et qui a aussi abandonné
les harkis en rase campagne
donc effectivement le moins qu'à la
réconciliation aujourd'hui le moment est
des signes positifs c'est un point
important qu'il faut pas minimiser de
vous voyez ça comme un signe positif
on va terminer chantal jouanno comme
chaque semaine ces démissions par le
plus de l'hebdo séquence culture
politique avec la sortie mercredi cette
semaine du film de bertrand tavernier
quai d'orsay et c'est thierry lhermitte
qui campe un dominique de villepin
impétueux ministre des affaires
étrangères notamment pendant la guerre
d'irak le film est adapté de la bd du
même nom entre comédie et politiques le
pitch avec simon barbarie j'ai rendez
vous avec le ministre
voulez-vous patienter les ministres
carmine un entretien cette semaine sort
dans les salles quai d'orsay de bertrand
tavernier
comment sarah camarades adapté de la
bande dessinée d'abel lanzac et
christophe blain
thierry lhermitte y incarne alexandre
taillard de vorms un ministre des
affaires étrangères bouillonnant
d'énergie est inspiré de dominique de
villepin
j'ai besoin d'une équipe arthur un
commando et genre et accuse toujours un
mouvement 24 heures sur 24
sanaa où il était super bien écrit les
dialogues extrêmement riche et bat donc
en travaillant en discutant avec
bertrand la gestuelle vient juste
appuyer le propos quoi voilà mais comme
le propos est particulier de couleur
gestuelle vie qui va avec est
particulière aux cibles légitimité taka
takata unités takka takka takka
efficacité sinon c'est une fiction au
plus près de la réalité grâce à abel
lanzac alias antonin baudry coscénariste
et ancien collaborateur de dominique de
villepin au quai d'orsay
j'ai appris énormément de choses et on
en apprend en plein dans le film parce
que vraiment entre la manière dont le
cabinet se travaille les questions au
gouvernement à l'assemblée nationale
il n'y a pas internet étrangères tout ça
c'est dingue
franchement c'est extraordinaire on
apprend tout ça enfin bon bien les
vacances bonne les rtt 7 en sur-régime
là attention dans la hotte et le thierry
lhermitte citoyen a une vision très
pragmatique de ce que devrait être
l'exercice du pouvoir
j'ai un peu sur deux copropriétaires de
mon pays
comme les 60 millions d'habitants et
donc d'employer un syndic pour
administrer voyez ce que je viens sadi
qui viennent ne peut exposer comment ils
ont géré puni maman d'apprendre suis là
combien il coûte voilà enfin de suivre
voilà je vous confie ce qu'il ya de plus
important
le langage parce que j'ai des
gouvernants on dépasse très largement ce
cadre là quand on est les délais sont
deux philosophies demeura le sortes de
choses qui - ne m'intéresse pas je
m'intéresse à la philosophie allemande
mais tu peux avoir une leçon de
philosophie je préfère lire les noms
d'un philosophe et puis je peu moins
bien un bon syndic
c'est ça qui me qui mouraient les gens
en général cherche pas salon cherche un
leader un guide tout ça va moins se
syndiquer et pour une leçon d'humour et
de politiques cette semaine un seul film
à voir qu'ils adorent c'est le discours
monsieur le ministre
merci camarade
voile alors c'est du cinéma mais qui
s'inspire en même temps de situations
vécues vous qui connaissez bien les
coulisses des cabinets ministériels est
ce que c'est réaliste
je n'ai pas vu le film et j'ai lu la
bella mais évidemment et en plus j'ai la
chance d'avoir été des deux soeurs que
j'ai été plus mais j'ai été ministre
avec la situation oui alors je connais
pas je connais pas dominique moi je veux
pas comparer mais c'est tellement vrai
mais c'est tellement vrai c'est du vécu
c'est vraiment ça dans les dents mais
casillas comme ça voilà les deux longs
comme dans les agences les coups tordus
les grands sourires les cetc très oui
les discours qu'on arrête de côté en
disant non on m'a écrit un discours mais
comprenez tellement mauvais match je
veux parler avec le coeur
c'est tellement vrai mais d'une façon
générale vous aimez regarder les films
ou lire les livres qui retrace
l'actualité politique
il ya deux de vos collègues du
gouvernent de l'ancien gouvernement qui
ont sorti des livres récemment rama yade
frédéric mitterrand est ce que ça ce
genre de livre vous les lisez ou pas ça
vous intéresse
globalement pas du tout sauf si c'est
sur le ton un peu justement de l'humour
de l'autodérision donc frédéric
mitterrand est vraiment dans les bourgs
j'avais beaucoup aimé le livre de
camille pascal parce que c'est pareil
c'est tellement reste c'est un peu dans
l'autodérision après sauf si c'est
vraiment des livres qui vont être sur
des terrains d'idées nouvelles
mais sinon très honnêtement je préfère
la littérature française et vous irez
voir le film merci beaucoup chantal
jouanno d'avoir été notre invité cette
semaine merci 4 merci on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine très au dessus de
programmes sur les chaînes
parlementaires et merci de votre
fidélité